I just finished recording with Noam
Chomsky this is just an editor's note
his audio is poor and there's nothing
that we can do this tends to happen when
someone changes location or if they're
not well versed enough to fix the issue
because they're not familiar with
computers enough they don't know how to
tweak the settings however there are
great questions from yoshabach from
Professor Avi Lo from Carl friston from
Philip Goff from Tim Maudlin so many
great questions so please endure persist
past it Donald Hoffman even has some
questions about space-time is doomed as
usual because Chomsky is not hearing
well I've printed out the questions for
him beforehand and so you'll hear me
refer okay go to question 25 go to
question 22 and so on this is because we
can't have a usual back and forth like
it would with a regular toe guest they
can hear me a regular tall guess but
Chomsky has a difficult time so we have
to stick straight to questions answers
questions answers okay now on to the
regular introduction this is the eighth
time that I've been lucky enough to
speak to Professor Chomsky the father of
modern Linguistics and in keeping with
the vein of toe we adhere to philosophy
Consciousness meaning rather than say
politics there's a playlist in the
description with each of chomsky's
theories of everything appearances
catalog below and coming up in about
three weeks I'll be posting a three hour
Behemoth compilation of the best of
gnomes philosophical thoughts on toe
with subtitles hard-coded in if you'd
like to volunteer some assistance to
double check that the captions are
indeed correct because there's plenty of
specialized terminology and names then
DM me on Twitter at Toe with Kurt that
is at
t-o-e-w-i-t-h-c-u-r-t enjoy this eighth
episode with Noam Chomsky thank you
Professor thank you for joining me for
the eighth time thank you it is to do it
again so yosha Bach asks what is the
most important unsolved problem in
cognitive science another
different criteria to determine what's
the most important problem
for the working
scientists the most important problems
and so are the ones right at the border
of understanding the ones that you have
some grasp about that approach but
haven't really solved those are the ones
you work on well with that Criterion
there's endless numbers of important
unsolved problems depending on what area
you're in you can enumerate any number
of them they won't be meaningful to
others unfamiliar with your area of
research I think what the problem may be
the question maybe driving at is
for reaching problems problems which
have large consequences in that case
there are also many but the most
important one from that I think of is
the problem
of voluntary action
so there's a famous
state of the art article on this two of
the leading researchers
mubt Roberta jamian came out in
a deadless journal American Academy a
couple years ago
and they went through what has been
discovered about this problem and what
remains unsolved and they put the
question
fancifully as they say at the end they
say we have
the grass fund had a deal with the
puppet and the the strings but we can't
say anything about the Puppeteer no
matter how much they search no matter
what experiments they care about neural
experiments and others you can't figure
out what lies behind
uh my decision to
to raise my finger versus not to or my
decision to give one rather than another
response to this question
well that is a very far-reaching
question I think it's completely
unresolved there are many many
scientists who feel that we have an
answer
the answer is determined by complex
physical laws and so on and so forth a
phenomena the structures that are much
too complex to deal with
thesis
that is vacuous
unverifiable if it makes you feel
comfortable to add it okay it's not
doing anything so I think that's a
completely unsolved problem
we'll go to question one C still
yoshibak in which ways did you update
your thinking on AI in the past five
years basically I haven't and the reason
is
not advanced in the last five years in
ways which have anything to do with my
thinking about it it has advanced in
many areas
but they just aren't related to my
thinking about it so for example there
are recent successes of the deep
learning programs which have cast light
significant light on serious problems of
science like protein folding the methods
that are used are
not of a kind that bear on alien
the preceding question asks whether the
recent successes of machine learning
surprise me
well that assumes that there are recent
successes
I don't know of any in the areas that I
work in mostly language
there's
lots of
achievements of all achievements that
receive plenty of enthusiastic
press commentary but when you look into
them and they're telling us basically
nothing so take the
GPT series which
has received a lot of
enthusiastic commentary or Lambda or
others like
I don't see what's successful about
these
what's it what has been shown is that
if you toss a couple of supercomputers
at 50 terabytes of data
that you can find surface regularities
which
if you put them together we lose people
into thinking that the program is doing
something
doesn't sound very interesting to me we
know that the programs are not doing
anything because uh
they fail the most Elementary condition
required for an explanation
namely that you see why things are this
way
and
crucially well they're known some other
way
if I come to a physics conference a I've
got a terrific Theory which should
includes all the laws of nature the ones
you've discovered the ones you haven't
yet determined and the theory is so
simple I can say it in Just Two Words
anything goes I don't get any prizes
doesn't say why things are not some
other word and that's what
all of these programs they were just as
well as impossible systems as for
possible ones my assistant if you give
it a corpus a massive purpose that
violates the basic principles of
language does it work fine maybe even
better so therefore whatever it's doing
it's not telling us anything about
language or
for ignition and it seems to me that all
of the systems that I'm familiar with
that have said problem so there's not no
successes that are surprising there are
very useful achievements so for example
the life transcription which I rely on
because I'm hard of hearing it's a fine
achievement that you took the trouble to
create it but it's telling us nothing
about the way humans interpretenses
whether they don't surprise me and if
there's been nothing to update my
thinking whether or a useful achievement
the 13th folding case
the next question is brains and minds
work very differently from today's
neural networks do you think that
today's approaches can be scaled and
improved to reach human-like
intelligence or do we need to divest
from Deep learning go back to the
drawing board and build something
different from scratch if we want to get
close to Human Performance no I don't
think the
deep learning approaches anything to do
makes the way Minds were they're very
useful a lot of serious sophisticated
math so whether major achievements but
it's about something different not the
way lines were in part for the reasons I
just mentioned doesn't distinguish the
way friends and Minds were from the way
they don't work as long as you don't
make that distinction there's nothing
said about our brains and Minds in a
specific case of language that I've
looked at most closely the problem is
exactly what I mentioned the systems
like the gbt series The Others do just
as well on non-lang which is on
languages so they're very much like that
imagine talk to the physics conference
it's not telling you anything bad
language by definition
okay the next one one e is consciousness
crucial to Building Systems that learn
think and create at a human level
Consciousness is part of the way humans
learn think and create
maybe not a very major Point most of
what are mental activities or both in
what's called learning thinking and
creating is inaccessible to
Consciousness so there's an awful lot
going on that we're totally unaware of
and can't become aware of the
Consciousness enters at some level here
and there so if anything is gonna
think learn and create the way humans do
you have to involve Consciousness that
when we say at a human level that opens
other questions what's the human level
you know we'd have to answer that before
we know that the answer to this question
then I don't never have any
characterization of at a human level
other than saying this is the way humans
do
presumably at a human level includes
things that are not the way humans do it
but somehow reach that level but then we
have to have a characterization of what
the level is I don't know of any
okay and number one F so the next one
are you a mysterian still in the sense
that understanding mind and
Consciousness is not possible for us or
do you feel there's a research direction
that you can sketch out first of all
I've never held that it's not possible
for which in fact I think we can
understand
quite a lot about my Consciousness there
are many questions that we have no
answers to even bad answers
the inquiry for ages still do like the
one I mentioned in citing beats season
[Music]
is that within the realm of possible
human understanding
again but it was back to an earlier
question are humans
organisms in the normal sense or the
outside the range of organisms I think
humans are organisms if so they're going
to be like other urbanisms their
capacities have and limits the scope and
the limits are related they have to do
with the internal essential nature of
the organism so if you're a say a rat
you can be trained to solve many kinds
of Mazes which can't solve
the prime number remains
in which you have to turn right at every
prime number option and the reason is
prime numbers just not within the
cognitive capacity of the red there are
many things that are not within America
of capacity so I happen to live in the
desert out of my backyard or desert ants
who have
minuscule brains but are capable of
cognitive achievements that humans can
attain like their navigation capacities
we can maybe duplicate it with
instruments to an extent but I can't
find my way around the world but ants
can so that's a limit to my passages
that we have other kinds of limits well
if we're organisms
within comes the question everyone's
interested in is something like the
ability to make distinctions whatever it
is is that is the explanation of the
outside the range of our Republic of
capacities it's an empirical question
why is there a research Direction you
can sketch out sure
the one that's pursued for example by
the beach in Nigeria
very good scientists they try to find
out they haven't been able to
be on their cognitive we simply don't
know
question number two
comes from Professor Donald Hoffman
2A what do you think about the claim
that Nema or Kani Hamed David Gross and
other physicists are making that space
time is doomed that we must look for new
structures utterly Beyond space-time and
quantum theory that give rise to
space-time and quantum theory
of these three questions a b and c
one of the first two A and B are utterly
beyond my competence to answer just
don't know enough of the final Theory
the arguments given so I can't say
anything about it okay so we'll go to 2C
what about what these discoveries of
letting go of space-time might entail
for the mind-body problem by Professor
Donald Hoffman
I have an opinion for whatever it's
worth
but they don't entail anything for the
mind-body problem because there is no
such problem
there was a mind-body problem at one
time
a classic good exposition of it is that
the court of course
Descartes
argued claimed in his physics that he
had and he was able to account for
aspects of the world including most of
the properties of humans by keeping
within what was called at the time the
mechanical philosophy philosophy just
meant science mechanical science it's
basic conception of science that held
from Galileo through Newton namely the
world is a complex of the kind that's
constructed by skilled artisans
at the time in Europe
that we considers
there was a proliferation of the complex
objects which are virtues that were
developed by having skilled Artisans
which amazed people in their
conformity in their similarities with
the humans could do or what other
animals could do then the basic
conception was well the world is just
something created by a incomparably more
skilled Artisan years levers and so on
Descartes thought
erroneously that his physical Theory
would account for almost all of nature
within this framework it wasn't accurate
I mean the systems didn't work in fact
one of Newton's contributions was to go
through it but it was understood by
other scientists wagons and others that
the arch physics just didn't work but he
had an explanation for everything in
those terms he then observed correctly
that there are certain things that don't
fall within mechanical explanation one
of his major pineapple in fact was
pretty much what I did before
except he was talking about language not
lifting your finger so he said the
capacity of humans in ordinary
discussion ordinary interchange ordinary
thought to
construct new expressions of thought
which have never occurred before and
which are appropriate to situations but
not caused by them that's the system he
was considering certainly seems to be a
normal property of human behavior
or you possibly that that doesn't fall
within mechanical science so therefore
as a scientist he postulated a new
principle risk kogi dance thinking
substance then you had a mind-body
broken how are these two substances
related that problem disappeared with
Newton
who showed that there are nobodies in
the Descartes sense there's a physical
entities in anything like the sense of
early modern science
the Newton himself thought this result
was completely absurd and seemed to
argued no person with any scientific
understanding could accept it in fact he
spent the rest of his life trying to
overcome finally and his contemporaries
like Wiggins did live and instead of
notice it what they were saying that it
wasn't that Newton's theories were
unintelligible they could understand the
theory is fine it was the kind of world
that he was postulating that was absurd
and in fact it's in that context that
Newton made his famous statement that uh
he proposes no hypotheses he was
providing just a mathematical Theory not
a physical Theory
kindly over time
Newton's
mathematical theories were accepted and
scientists lost interest in whether the
theory if the theory was intelligible
whether what it described was
intelligible that question doesn't
appeared as far as I can see the Mind
probably mind-body problems disappeared
with it we have no conception of body
other than what our best theories
postulate which just as well includes
mine in fact John Locke from that
conclusion right away said for all we
know the
organized matter just as properties we
can't conceive of like action
interaction without contact contact so
it may also have properties like
thinking you can put this in a
theological context that we can drop
that soon through the 18th century very
extensively from thinking matter what
properties of matter you thinking where
matter is whatever the world is
constituted of you know we still have
basically no answers then so it's I just
don't see how a mind-body problem at
least in the classical sense in the
formula
I don't know of any other things in
which you can
question number three this one comes
from Professor Avi Loeb
coffee helps me work it helps me fast
from carbs it's become one of the best
parts of my day consistently that's why
I'm delighted that we're collaborating
with Trade coffee they partner with top
independent Roasters to Freshly roast
and send the finest coffee in the
country directly to your home on your
preferred schedule this matters to me as
I work from home their team of experts
do all the work testing hundreds of
disparate coffees to land on a final
curated collection of 450 exceptional
coffees I chose these three and the team
at Trade coffee worked to create a
special lineup for theories of
everything for the tow audience based on
some questions they asked me such as how
much caffeine do I enjoy and what's the
bitterness ratio Etc you can get that
line up or if that's not let's say your
cup of coffee then you can take your own
quiz on their website to find a set that
matches your specific profile if you'd
like to support small businesses and
Brew the best cup of coffee you've ever
made at home then it's time to try Trade
coffee right now trade is offering our
listeners thirty dollars off your first
order plus free shipping at
drinktrade.com everything that's
drinktrade.com everything for thirty
dollars off this one comes from
Professor Avi Loeb
imagine that we will develop sentient AI
systems and these will be able to
interact with each other do you expect
them to develop their own kinship
including a language that is more
advanced than human languages and that
humans will not be able to follow in
such a case they might be able to
establish their own Society of AI
systems we could always unplug them from
their electric outlet although some will
view that as equivalent to murder
I'm going to answer this question
we have to have a concept of
sentient AI systems
there certainly are
if by sanctioned we mean capable of
interacting with one another responding
to other one or another States and so on
responding to features of the
environment that are significant for our
choice of action and so on if that's
what we mean by it there are many
sentient systems the humans
and removes trees to take trees trees
are sentient in this sense okay the
forests the trees interact with women
they send signals to one another they
change what they do be dependent on the
signals they've received from others of
course they respond to the environment
so they seem to be sentient systems in
any sense of the word that I know of
they do interact with each other they
don't develop their own kinship or a
language and so on the answer to whether
sentient systems will do this is well
obviously not because plenty don't
they're just as animals don't whatever
that sentient AI systems well that
depends on how an AEI system differs
from natural systems
with an AI system
basically an AI system is a program
the program is basically a theory that
is presented in a notation that the
computer can implement
so we're basically asking that can we
develop sentient theories
I'm not sure exactly what that means
maybe theories of sentience
can we develop theories of sentience
and now we're back to the earlier
questions is this within to a certain
extent of course we can we have many
such theories are they complete no
they're not complete but of course we
expect theories not to be complete is
the possibility of completing them
within human cognitive capacity we never
know if we agree that we're organisms
if we're mysterians in that sense yes
we're organisms Not Angels then could be
could not be so I don't see how to
pursue the question any further
for these reasons
okay question number four from Professor
Carl friston
do you think machines will ever talk to
each other or us and let's define talk
as posing questions and answers in the
service of resolving uncertainty about
the world or one another what I'm
getting at here is whether any sentient
artifact
can communicate with another sentient
artifact or whether two artifacts have
to share a common ground or narrative
that inherits from them having the same
kind of phenotype and experiences well
let's take trees again there's sanctions
natural artifacts the sheer Common
Ground a narrative in some sense which
they inherit and they do interact with
one another
so there are natural objects that have
this property well let's go back to
machines personal remember what we all
know when in this framework that we're
discussing artificial intelligence when
we talk about machines we don't mean the
physical object
we mean the program Alan Church
initiated the Contemporary field of
artificial intelligence with this famous
1950 paper on can machines think he
didn't mean that there's a computer
think he meant is there a program that
thinks
the question as you recall as being too
meaningless to deserved discussion
because we have no clear concept of
thinking
proposed some alternative concept is
imitation again
so when we ask whether
machine sensored artifacts will talk to
each other we're asking or the programs
that can interact with each other I
suppose so why not enough trees can do
it we can construct a program that can
do it they have to share some kind of
common ground or they won't be able to
interact but they do have experiences
they're affected by the environment same
type of phenotype yes in some sense
there's going to be something common
about them
so it seems to me the
questions first I understand it maybe
I'm missing something the question seems
to be to be left at that level that can
we construct programs which will pose
and answer questions they won't resolve
uncertainty about the world because the
programs have no concept of certainty
about the world just doesn't arise for
programs people using the programs might
find that they resolve some uncertainty
about the world just as the programs for
protein folding did resolve some
uncertainty about the world or
say a theorem proving program which say
used Brute Force to prove theorems
starting with the axioms running through
all possible proofs from shortest to
longer you'll find the a proof efficient
theorem well that would relieve
uncertainty about mathematics but the
program wouldn't know anything about it
we know about it
the next question number five
Professor Tim maudlin
he said because I emailed him and asked
him if he had any questions for you
actually I just mentioned Chomsky in my
graduate class I said because I heard
this that Chomsky was inspired to
postulate Universal grammar because of
Goodman's new riddle of induction
that is
because that Riddle That Chomsky thought
there must be some a priori constraint
on natural languages in order that
they're learnable I'm curious whether
this is historically accurate and if it
is do you still think Universal grammar
is the right way to express this
constraint
will
I assume you know it because you know
riddle is
but it very simply he was asking
which kinds of predicates are
projectable in the sense that they fit
into law-like statements and we can use
them to what's coming next so the
example the famous example that he gave
was the predicate Group G or you mean
which is defined as meaning
green Before Time t or t is sometime in
the future the blue After Time T and
then take a little bit of emeralds
we were before time tea they're all
green they're all grew but depending on
whether we project green or grew will
make a different prediction for After
Time T then Goodman argued that grew is
not projectable and green is projectable
actually I was a student of his when he
was working this out and discussing it
in courses that's basically that it had
to answer the question it had nothing to
do with me and views on universal
grammar I frankly did not think that his
explanation about the distinction of
that he gave an argument to try to show
that green was projectable and grew
wasn't was never convinced that the
argument went through uh it was of
course familiar with the hume's argument
which Goodman discusses in his book but
not quite accurately hume's famous
argument about induction is
as Hume put it you have to assume that
it's carried on because of Aid and what
he called animal instinct we have an
instinct as animals that leads us to
accept the inductive reasoning in
certain cases not others in a way
spelled it up more carefully with some
predicates and not others and yes I
think that's the only answer to carrying
out induction to the extent that we do
some animal Instinct but I don't think
you need that Insight in order to
postulate Universal gram and it's just
that there's no alternative I mean there
was a time when I was a student in fact
back in the 1940s 1950s it was assumed
that the language acquisition is a
matter of training and habit including
the leading American League was still
there in Bloomfield philosophy of
language took essentially the same view
perhaps most influential
anglo-american philosopher of language
in mind for him language was a complex
of dispositions to respond
established by uh in his picture and by
scanarian operative operant condition
those views Fall by the wayside as soon
as you take a look at the acquisition of
language it's nothing like them an
acquisition of language is based on what
Hume called an animal instinct there's
some capacity that a human infant has
that it's that chimpanzee doesn't have
which enables the human
infant to quickly acquire the language
on the basis of
scatter data which for the chimp is just
noise
that's gotta be
because of some animal Instinct if you
like some innate capacity that's about
as Elementary as you can be but if
there's in any capacity there should be
a theory of that innate capacity
the term Universal grammar in the modern
sense is just the name for that theory
so postulating human Universal grammars
Elementary rationality there's no
alternative is it the right way to
proceed expressing the constraints I
can't think what alternative there is if
you believe that there's something
innate that distinguishes the infant
from its pet chimp which is certainly
true and then this is what you have to
constantly
okay question 17 so 1 7 17 17.
this is from Professor Philip Goff
we both agree with Russell that physics
tells us what matter does but fails to
reveal its intrinsic nature therefore
the only thing we know directly about
the intrinsic nature of matter is that
some of it I.E the stuff in brains is
experiential so either the matter
outside of brains also has an
experiential intrinsic nature or it has
some other property completely unknown
nature
surely the former option I.E pan
psychism is to be preferred on grounds
of Simplicity what do you make of this
argument
well simplicity
depends on the Simplicity of a theory
depends on the evidence that you're
considering
consider different evidence different
theories will be simpler or more
difficult
so let's uh accept the basic framework
generally accepted in contemporary
philosophy
within which this question arises uh
goes back to a distinction
goes back to David
chalmer's distinction between the easy
problems of Consciousness and the heart
problem
the hard problem is supposed to be what
is it like to see a sunset
that's the hard problem the easy problem
is
what are the
neurological genetic other properties
that enter into being conscious of the
sensitive I've never been particularly
happy with that formulation because
it's not very clear to me what the hard
problem is if I'm asked what is it like
to see the sunset that you're looking at
I can give a very detailed answer
red spot up here makes me feel happy and
go on and fit that an extensive detail
so there's no problem in describing what
it's like to see that Sunset but if I'm
asked what is it like to see a sunset I
don't think that has an answer at least
I can't imagine what the answer is
and if a question doesn't have a
formulable answer it's not an authentic
question it's just a linguistic
expression in the interrogative form
it's a kind of On a par with the way to
things happen
has the form of a question but it's not
a real question there's no conceivable
answers so the hard problem is as far as
I can see
doesn't really exist we're left with the
easy problem which is of course very far
from Easy know what's going on when I
see the sunset and I'm conscious of it
what I can describe in detail what's
going on it's within that context that
the questions raised now one answer to
it is all of Nature has the property of
Consciousness that's one possibility
another possibility another answer that
is often given
is there is no consciousness it's an
illusion stuck with either of those
answers I think we can expect to find an
answer which will say that Consciousness
is a property of humans
other animals but not the table on which
my computer is resting
uh is that a list sample answer than
pansychism depends on what our evidence
is so suppose someday we get real
answers to the so-called easy problem
suppose we find the neurological
properties genetic properties that enter
into accounting for my
Moments Of Consciousness and for what is
not what I know without Consciousness
like most of my mental activities I
suppose we find a way of distinguishing
those and distinguishing humans from
tables well then the simplest argument I
think will take into account all of this
these discoveries and information
and then I don't think and psychism any
longer is the simplest answer
it's an answer that simply postulate
something for which there's no evidence
that particles have this property even
though we already have evidence that
only
certain kinds of organization of
whatever the world is constituted of of
this property
so Simplicity depends on what you're
accounting for
the Simplicity of the theory depends on
what it's dealing with if we take the
full range of evidence that we hope to
have by making progress with the
so-called easy problem then I think we
have simpler theories okay 24. do you
have a resolution to the Liars paradox
no nothing to say about the paradoxes
that is it all new and a lot has been
said about them but I have nothing to
add what about the Raven paradox
same story that's temples Paradox again
I think they're reasonable answers but I
have nothing to add to them okay 26 so
the next one
each word in a dictionary is defined in
terms of other words in the dictionary
which indicates that there are some
fundamental concepts which have to be
understood without reference to other
words like the axioms of a language or
that somehow the meaning of the words
are inextricably tied to the relation
that each word has to others are these
the only two options
well we have to ask ourselves
what are we talking about human language
or are we talking about
formal systems that somebody constructed
like say made of mathematics or quantum
theory there are different answers in
these two occasions
in the case of a formal system that
someone constructs uh yes there have to
be some fundamental concepts in terms of
which others are defined that's true for
metal mathematics it's true for physics
to the extent that it's formalized and
so on so then in that context yes it's
great what about human language
well in human language the question
doesn't arise
because words in the dictionary don't
have definitions when you look up a
dictionary say most detailed dictionary
and find the OED I'm going to take a
look at the definition of word there
it's nowhere near a definition it's an
explanation which gives the number of
hints that enable you with your Rich
intuitive understanding of language to
guess what the word means that you're
doing most of the word your mind the
dictionary is doing almost nothing
you try to define a simplest word you
can think of the
table and a river and cats or whatever
you want as a rich and complex meaning a
one which incidentally is known to
infants without experience which poses
another fundamental promise to this
problem how are infants able to acquire
the rich and complex meaning of the most
Elementary words with only very few
presentations as has been shown by
experimental studies series none of
those go back to the first question one
of those deep ones which we live in
unreal the answer to but there are no
definitions there really many
definitions for technical terms that are
made up so if somebody
introduces the term
tensor let's say uh they get the
definition of it but these are not the
kinds of words that are just acquired in
the ordinary life those words don't have
definitions but they are interrelated in
all sorts of ways but there's no
particular reason to believe that some
other I mean to some extent some are
about more fundamental than others but
there's no we have no reason to believe
that there's some finite set which is
the basis like an axiom system I might
add here just for those of you are
interested that there is a very
interesting work in dealing with a
question of how we use our
lexical items what words are not really
the right units but the minimal meaning
but bearing items how do we use them
there's two different theories about
this one is that it's called the burst
for Simplicity one is that the words are
stored we have a store of words in our
mind we access the words when we're
trying to understand the sentence
that's pretty much the standard Theory
this is an alternative which is quite
interesting developed mostly by Alec
Marantz
linguist
neuroscientist at NYU he's argued that
we don't store the words we store the
rules for creating words and whether a
word is actually in the used in the
Lexicon or not is kind of irrelevant and
has quite interesting arguments
neurological
super linguistic and others arguing that
the storage is actually just the
generative rules not the words
themselves
so possible word which doesn't happen to
be in our lexicon see Blake has treated
the same way as one that is that's quite
an interesting scientific question
Dawkins introduced the concept of
extended phenotype is there any relation
between language and extended phenotype
depends what we mean by language
the language is one of those
informal terms of
General usage as much too imprecise to
discuss so like anything else in the
Sciences when linguists try to discuss
and understand something about language
or psychologists certain neurologists
they give a technical definition of
language so for example if
a physicist is asked what's energy
what's work what's been they're not
going to give you the definition that's
in ordinary language there are no
definitions what they'll do is Define
the technical term
which is different from the one in
ordinary language and the same is true
here so we have to ask what do we mean
by language
well if we mean the
technical notion that
I would call eye language internal
language then extended phenotypes have
nothing to do with
if we use the word language in a loose
figurative common sense then you know
maybe extended phenotypes have something
to do with it
is our obsession with the Turing test a
holdover of the influence of behaviorism
does a behavior however convincing ever
decisively imply Consciousness should we
be using some other test other than the
Turing test
first of all I might mention as a
historical fact that
the touring just as she goes back in the
17th century
uh after the courts postulation of a
second substance for things like the
creative use of language uh is
Associates mainly jacked according one
took the obvious next step and said can
we discover
experimental tests that will tell us
whether a creature that looks like us
has this property or not then he went
through various things which are kind of
like during his imitation gain
so that's basically the Turing test but
there it was uh for a fundamental
scientific reason to find out a property
of an or of an organism well as I said
that kind of disappeared with Newton uh
does if we can test behaviors with the
tourings during his imitation game
does that imply Consciousness no no you
could make up a program that can do it
which has no consciousness
shouldn't we be using some other test
depends what we're trying to achieve
I don't see any particular purpose in
trying to understand to determine
whether a machine is doing some of the
machine meaning program is doing
something like thinking but if we regard
it
a significant question we use whatever
test that fits at a particular
definition
of thinking or whatever religion
okay question number 30. with colorless
ideas that swim furiously you showed
that you can have syntactic sense
without semantic sense outside of idioms
and common phrases can something make
semantic sense without being syntactic
so if so can this apply to math or
physics that is it seems like in math
and physics as soon as you don't have
syntactic sense then the whole equation
the mathematical sentence is not well
posed and thus is meaningless can you
imagine cases where we have ill-defined
mathematical statements that have
meaning
plenty of examples in the history of
mathematics so take for example the
there was take just something as simple
as arithmetic or geometry I mean
arithmetic and
geometry word study highly productively
literally for Millennia before the
concepts were well defined no there
wasn't a will to find
there were good serious in the modern
sense definition of basic concepts of
arithmetic until about the 1860s and
bayana caves will defined in the
concepts of arithmetic Persona
geometry wasn't formalized until Gilbert
around 1900
but of course it had been used forever
productively and effectively and it's
not until the formalization that they're
well defined kind of a famous case is
the concept of limit you go back to the
17th century calculus Newton blood this
is calculus were based on some intuitive
concept of limit
in fact there's a loan debate in the
history of mathematics as to whether
Newton's proofs actually involve in
equivocation
in the use of zero
is it the case that in one line Newton
used zero to mean zero and another line
you use it to mean as small as possible
he had no the theory of them well long
debated but then but what happened
apparently
histories of mathematics say I don't
know much about this myself I'm just
relying on the histories the British
mathematicians worked hard on trying to
sharpen and clarify the Notions
which actually wasn't really done until
mid 19th century
Continental mathematic mathematicians
basically ignored it
and Gauss the other boiler the other
very mathematicians and they developed
most of the classical analysis based on
ill-defying Notions where the British
mathematicians for the most part were so
I mean because they didn't really have a
clear notion well so yes you can
certainly imagine such cases in fact
there are plenty of them there were two
additional questions one Anonymous and
the other by Professor Norman wildberger
which we didn't get to so we got to over
email professor Norman weiberger says
here's a question I would like to ask
Professor Chomsky is there any
linguistic evidence for Universal or
almost Universal innate mathematical
Notions in humans maybe Notions is not
the right word here if not how does one
frame a meaningful question in this
direction and now I'll get a computer to
read chomsky's answer definitely
knowledge of arithmetic is a classic
case the topic of a famous debate
between Darwin and Wallace
both recognized that knowledge of
arithmetic is universal though it
plainly couldn't have been selected
Wallace suggested some new Force
operating in evolution
Darwin was unwilling to accept that
it plainly must be innate
there's no way to learn that the
integers go on forever
there's some reason to believe that it
may have the same Origins as the
language faculty
the simplest language would have a
single lexical item and the simplest
rule internal merge
that yields the successor function and
the rudiments of addition
from there it's not hard to go on to
addition
so whatever rewiring of the brain that
yielded recursive enumeration apparently
unique to humans could have provided the
basis for both language and arithmetic
as for mathematics generally that's
another matter
there's a famous comment of kroneckers
that God created the natural numbers and
Man created the rest which translates as
arithmetic is innate but human
creativity whatever that is created the
set theory and on from there and the
second question is how far does grammar
extend people talk about the grammar of
narratives and stories or the grammar of
video games such as common tropes and
patterns ingrained in players that are
unconscious and widely used across
almost each video game is this a
generalization of grammar that bears
only a passing resemblance to the
linguistic concept of grammar or is
there some common neurological even
psychological basis between these types
of quote unquote grammars there's no
clear answer we can extend terms to
broader uses like quote unquote the
language of the Stars it's not arbitrary
but there are no clear principles the
term grammar without any such
metaphorical extensions is itself much
too imprecise to use in studying
language so it's given a technical
meaning just as is done in the Sciences
generally
well I'm sorry but I have afraid I
haven't
appointment in two minutes that I have
to go to
thank you thank you professor
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l that is Kurt J
Mongol it's support from the patrons and
from the sponsors that allow me to do
this full-time every dollar helps
tremendously thank you